I can get I can be a little bit of a
hothead he's quite a little more calm
and has a more even demeanor to him
which I thought I think we pair together
very well that way but it's I think
we're pretty close to where when he
knows how I am and I know how he is so
regardless of how we are on a given
minute or a given play we're both
competitive people and we both know
we're both here to try to help each
other be the best we can be in whenever
you have that you can just genuinely
coach someone and not have to worry
about anything else just whatever's in
your mind you let it come out of your
mouth and when someone knows what your
intentions are and I'm who you are as a
person it really doesn't matter how you
show your person Hollywood College Ana
had 49ers coach talking about his
interactions with quarterback Jimmy
Garoppolo and I think what he said there
is so insightful and it's so appropriate
and you know when you have the right
relationship with somebody you're
working with and they understand we're
all in this together we're all trying to
do what's best you don't have to tiptoe
around what you want to say no right
right like Jon Gruden has to do with
Derek Ashur and like he didn't have to
do with you like you knew even though
Gruden wore you out right
you knew the broader goal was to make
the football team as good as it could be
there was a method to the madness
assistant used to come up to me and go
listen if he if he wasn't yelling at you
then you should be worried if he wasn't
mad at you and always challenged you
then you should be worried it was kind
of his way yeah he showed he had he had
some faith in me like this guy could be
something so I'm gonna be hard on him
and exactly right you gotta have thick
skin and then you definitely do with
Kyle because Kyle's he's blunt and is in
your faces you're gonna find as far as
an NFL head coach and the common goal is
to make the team as good as it can be
the right player as good as he can be
this is how you coach this is how you
improve this is how you prepare guys for
the fires that inevitably happen when
you're out there on the field and there
is confusion and everything's going
haywire and you have to decide what I'm
going to do how do you get yourself to
the point where you can make those calm
rational even-handed decisions in
moments of high duress and stress that's
what they're preparing exactly right
that's what you've said before going out
onto the field was a welcome relief from
dealing with Jon Gruden because you
didn't have to listen to him when you're
on the exactly right I didn't have
enough
paulien standing eight yards behind me
going you know get out of the huddle get
out of the huddle ten nine eight hurry
up you dolt hurry up hurry I mean that's
what he used to do to me to where I
could still remember being on the field
in my first preseason game going oh my
gosh this is amazing without this guy
back there I mean I don't have to deal
with him yelling at me and I feel free
and the game was easy and that was the
method behind his madness and you know
he was nothing he's not the first coach
to do that Shanahan's like that you know
Shanahan first off as you know he's
smart he has a vision of what he wants
in the offense and he wants a
quarterback that yeah can make plays but
more or less is gonna be a machine and
listen to him you know that's where he
got successful with that Ryan an even
match job with the Houston Texans
because he would say hey and this
coverage just read this guy I'm gonna
make it really simple for you you just
got to read this one guy and then you
throw to the opposite guy who he's not
covering and if you don't do that you're
an idiot for not listening to Kyle for
one and of course he's gonna go crazy
and you're gonna end up being on the
bench but he's gonna make life easy on
you that way but he's gonna demand a lot
of you two to make sure you listen and
and carry what do I want to say carry
his message and everything that he's
taught you through the week into the
game it reminds me of something Rex
Grossman said in 2011 after the lockout
ended because he was one of the
contenders become the starting
quarterback in Washington where Kyle was
the offensive coordinator yeah and they
asked Grossman does he think he has a
chance to win the job and he said yes I
do well why do you think that because
I'm gonna do exactly what Kyle tells me
to do right
I know that's how you get the path to
the playing time you do what Kyle says
and you're gonna be the quarterback and
he ended up winning the starting job
because he did the things that Kyle
wanted to do he ran the offense the way
Kyle wanted him to run it yeah I mean
you know I used to have this argument
with Kyle every now and then because he
talked tell me about quarterbacks set
you know I think you can win a Super
Bowl with that quarterback and I would
go I know you can I would go maybe you
can cuz your offense but I was just like
the rest of the NFL doesn't view that
guy as a Super Bowl type quarterback but
yes you know to everything we've talked
about of Kyle with is his knowledge of
defenses his just you know fearlessness
and designing plays that have never been
seen before in the NFL or doing any of
that
he really knows what he's doing he's
broken it down he lives it and he's
gonna give you a contingency plan for
all if the plan fails like fails anyways
so you're gonna have every answer and
feel comfortable that way as a
quarterback so yeah you should listen to
them you shouldn't do like oh I'm RG
three and I'm really fast and I'm just
gonna kind of like make crap happen you
know what happens if you do that well
you end up being on the bench for the
next five years your career we spend a
lot of time talking about the
opportunity that the Bears had to take
Patrick mahomes instead of Mitchell true
Biscay we never talk about the fact that
the 49ers you're right took Solomon
Thomas who's been our age of
disappointment instead of Patrick
mahomes with I reminded him once or
twice but and that's I feel like Patrick
mahomes is the kind of guy that Kyle
Shannon wouldn't want because he feels
that there's a lower chance of Patrick
mahomes running the offense the gray
wants it to be run yeah it's a great I
think there's a faction of coaches and
football who were scared of people like
Patrick mahomes because they think oh
he's just gonna be cocky and so talented
he's gonna do want to do whatever he
wants and he's not gonna listen to me
and I just I disagree I've had this
conversation with Kyle - that guy will
listen to you he's gonna listen to you
he just he's been put in an environment
right now where Andy Reid wants him to
listen but Andy Reid also gives them the
ability to play some backyard football -
it's not the same as Kyle he kind of
goes okay here we go we're gonna attack
it but if it doesn't work hey you got
these talents and you attack it this way
and they kind of hash it out that way
yeah Kyle doesn't necessarily run his
offense like that but I do think there
is yeah Kyle and a few other coaches out
there they want robots at quarterback
but then when it's a big game and the
defense is all over their offense all of
a sudden they want oh I want a guy that
can scramble around and make a place
where do I get one of those guys well I
don't know you wanted the robot so you
didn't get them so yeah I think I think
Kyle has come to the realization that
yes guys like that can be taught like
Patrick mahomes and things like that
where he doesn't he doesn't necessarily
need to be what do I want to say the
goody-two-shoes borderline backup or not
super talented basically and the
criticism I had at the time yeah Kyle
when I saw rex grossman quotes is Kyle
basically wants to be the kid with the
joystick on the sidelines who is
NIP y elating everything the quarterback
shot right do it the way I draw you to
do it not the way that you think you
should do it or could do it or maybe can
do it instead of the way I want you to
do it if you do it the way I want you to
do it we're gonna be successful yeah
yeah I think there is a lot a lot of
that and he's like that with his
coaching staff too he wants those guys
that conveyed the message he's giving in
the coaching the coaching room but
that's what makes a great head coach hey
Bill Belichick I don't think it's a
whole lot different that way too but
yeah there's got to be a little bit of a
you know give-and-take with with it I
think a guy like Patrick mahomes as may
be compared to a guy like Jimmy
Garoppolo yeah there would have to be
you know I always think about about of a
clip between it's the Falcons Broncos
Super Bowl right and John Elway's miked
up for that game right it's his last
game ever he throws that deep bomb to
Rod Smith right they come out of the
timeout right so he's going out there to
run that play and you know hey if you
get the look throw the post and John
runs back and goes well wait what if I
don't get the look and Michael accept me
goes that's why we pay you all the money
make something happen right so that's
got it that's gonna happen especially as
you get deep into the playoffs the Super
Bowl not everything's gonna be exactly
as you expect it to be and your
quarterbacks gonna have to make play and
Garoppolo as shown moments of doing that
this year one quick point on that before
we turn to Garoppolo yeah
when you were talking about Patrick
mahomes and how he plays and then Andy
Reed has figured out how to coach him I
can't not think about Andy Reid's
experience in Green Bay oh right right
right if you don't go through the highs
and lows of Brett Favre and understand
maybe how to properly put parameters on
a guy like right you want nothing to do
with Patrick mahomes right uuugh I think
that's a very real thing but when you
start to see okay I did get you know I
did get some parameters on Brett Favre
and we saw what it ended up being and I
don't think my Holmes is as crazy as
Brett Favre naturally to begin with
anyways and I mean that in a good way
just not as the loose canon personality
or a loose canon with the ball as
compared to Brett Favre but you're right
that's how to have helped him out to
give a little bit of like we were just
saying again that leeway to go okay
here's the play but if it doesn't work I
traded up on the draft for you to get me
out of this Jam now my play didn't work
make something happen and more times
than not he does so kyle has his robot
in Jimmy Garoppolo and he's found a
cheat code recently which is hand the
ball off hand the ball and the ball off
and it is such a strange time
when you think about the criticism that
Jimmy Garoppolo is absorbing it has
nothing to do with anything he's done
yeah it has everything to do with what
he hasn't done right he hasn't thrown we
were at the game the divisional round
matchup between the Vikings and the
49ers and even though the stat sheet
doesn't show it I think there was a
palpable sense in the stadium the Kyle
got a little freaked out yeah by some
close calls from Garoppolo and decided
let's just run the ball and it worked no
down I'm gonna keep running the ball
until they can stop it and they didn't
stop it so we don't need to throw right
19 total passes that game and then the
next week hey what the hell let's run
the ball until they stop at all they
can't stop it will run at 42 times will
pass at eight times but that's the
proper going into the Superbowl right
Chris how do you flip the switch on if
you're Garoppolo if you have been
essentially mothballed over the past
couple of weeks they're gonna call upon
you potentially win the game with your
arm if they can't run the ball how can
you expect them to do it when he hasn't
been expected to do it at any point the
postseason yeah well you know I think
you the the the the Packer game in
general is different he made a few
completions and nice throws early on
they got up and they just never had a
rely on the pass game and like you said
they just dominated that that way but
it's not like he's mentally checked out
and we've seen him playing a lot of big
moments this year I don't think this is
gonna I would be shocked if they won
this game the same way we saw them when
they're two playoff games Jimmy
Garoppolo I would expect is going to
have to do more in this one one you know
Kansas City's run defense it's it's
better than Minnesota's in Green Bay so
just there's no other way around it it's
been one of the better run defenses in
football over the last seven eight nine
weeks of the year so from that
standpoint especially with spagnolo who
again let's not forget him in this this
matchup this is another guy who's shown
great creativity and guts when he's had
two weeks to prepare for Super Bowls
both times of the Giants were phenomenal
little game plans there so you know I
look at that and go okay he's gonna have
some curveballs so we're Shanahan's not
gonna be able to just dictate the run
game I think all game long
I think Garoppolo will be fine I think
he knows his role and his team and like
Kyle said I don't think he's a guy
that's like you know like you and me
where we might have overanalyze every
little thing we say and do in a day or
whatever I think Jimmy Garoppolo is I
gotta completion what's the next play oh
okay great
oh is this play okay
I think he can wipe the slate clean very
easily you've said it yourself and his
respectful away as you can he's kind of
a meathead yeah and he's not gonna be
freaked out right and he's not gonna be
flustered hey baby
play if they win the Super Bowl and he
throws it eight times so be it if he
throws it 38 times so be it do whatever
he has to do I think so and that's what
adds to this mystique this intrigue this
drama about how those four quarters of
football will play out and how much of
what we see in the first quarter is
going to echo in two quarters to
criterion for how much will the game
change before our very eyes fascinating
it I'm excited for what's sick I feel
like of that as excited as ever they
make you wear a wristband maybe wear a
wristband I got the fashion statement
you got the dispensation for the
wristband they probably don't have a
wristband big enough they just trust me
they just trust me they want to make
sure they got tabs yeah it's funny I had
to I had to run my pass a few times
before it finally turned green yeah it
was like a few phone calls yeah Roger
was like don't let that jerk in again
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports